[Music]
thank you
now let's talk about sourdough Judy
bindel who trans is here I'm a much
loved spectator contributor uh has
written a piece and it's on our website
called just saying no to Salado and the
stand first is put it in the bin and
this piece Has Gone Bananas on the
inside I think it said it might be our
most read piece of the year so far uh
and it's a vicious attack really on
sourdough bread
um let's start with the obvious question
what's your problem with sourdough
everything
look
first of all I'm delighted that it's
doing so well but sometimes I put huge
amounts of time and effort Blood Sweat
and Tears writing about awful violence
against women and girls terrible
unsolved crimes
and sourdough does better than that yeah
I'm going to become a food Christian
huge amount but this is actually quite
funny because it's been brewing in my
head for a long time and I've been
kicking off about it with my friends in
restaurants even in bakeries high-end
bakeries where I live in crush on Crouch
end
where everywhere I look there's two
sourdough people asking for sourdough
restaurants with different cuisines
all serving it and so my problem with
sourdough twofold first I don't like its
taste or Texture which is pretty kind of
basic
and secondly it's become a little bit
like I suppose 1986 in East Berlin
before the Wall came down where you were
queuing for bread and there was one type
of bread and that was it this is East
Berlin in 1986. it's colonized the
entire bread world
I'm old enough to remember the kiwi
fruit Fad in the 1980s every single dish
that you
ordered in every restaurant had a slice
of this Abomination on top of it
ugly it tasted vile and it was just seen
as something that you couldn't serve a
meal without and then all of a sudden it
dropped off the radar and everybody went
back to rightly so hating kiwi fruit
with sourdough it's different because
obviously it was going to be a type of
bread that some people would really like
it suits their palette it suits why and
how they eat bread
but during lockdown and there was a big
yeast shortage in 2020
the recipe went viral around all of
these bored people working from home or
furloughed and had too much time in
their hands and it was guess what you
can make this type of bread the type of
bread that you get in these Posh very
upper middle class you know North London
bakeries without yeast so that then did
the rounds on Instagram and people were
no longer posting their photographs of
their holidays and their meals out in
restaurants and their nights stoshes in
bars and so all of a sudden we started
to see these really ugly pictures of
over baked crusted bread with massive
cracks in them and people holding them
out like some burned offering and even
bringing them around and leaving them on
the doorstep because of course we
couldn't you know social distancing I
opened my door once and there was a loaf
of bread
and a text message from a friend saying
thought you'd like this and I thought
well okay I've never liked this stuff
but how kind of her to do this yeah so I
tried to eat it with soup no chance
because it's so hard and the crust is so
uncompromising that you can dip it in
soup the soup just falls off it back
into the bowl they won't absorb it so I
tried to dip it in a bit of olive oil
and had it with
some snacks that wouldn't work because
it won't absorb the olive oil and of
course trying to make a sandwich with it
you would honestly need a jaw this size
and you would be chewing it forever and
then you'd need to go to the dentist and
it was locked down and there were no
dentists open so I thought maybe after
lockdown it will start to get
unpopular made of people that have had
enough it's actually got even more
stratospherically
yes popular amongst people why well I
think I could answer that question a
little bit uh because your piece heard
my feelings slightly because I am as you
would put it a a bread bro I'm a bread
Brooke but you don't look like want to
be fair I've never tried to be a kind of
hipster or anything like that but I what
happened is a few months ago
I went to a friend's house and we had
some bread in the morning uh and I said
the street delicious and she said oh
I'll give you some my starter which as
you notice he said in piece is the South
American culture yeah uh so she gave me
something I put it in the car and I
didn't really think I was going to
actually use it I just took it but then
quite bored that evening I decided to
give a go and I realized it's actually
incredibly easy
and you get a lot of compliments to
doing something that's incredibly easy
uh and I also think looking after the
mother of the starter is a bit like
gardening it has its own pleasure
because he'll sort of literally not
you're looking for a live culture but
anyway as a result I did I've actually
brought because I do bring it into the
office
to make
um prepared earlier and so I'm not sure
we've ever done this on spec TV before
but here is uh it's not been very uh
nice but here's here's some sourdough
breaths that I've made
uh this is I'm here under false
pretenses I was not told that this was
part of my punishment and did you want
butter I will try a little bit about
because that's the only way that it
might actually slip down in yeah okay
just have a taste I will have a taste
because you didn't complain about how
hard brother crossed it well you know
the thing is that what I found was when
I was eating sourdough is that the taste
of blood doesn't really go well with
bread and that's what was happening I
actually had a mouse injury thank you
very much I had a mouse injury
government you actually have cut here on
My Lip from trying to chew a bit of
sourdough that collie bought me yes
thinking that I would like it because
everyone else does okay
eight days
you've changed your line completely I
can't wait for the reaction
it's very nice
great
this is like Paul Hollywood reviewing um
a cake
it's very nice but no disrespect mum
taken this is very different
from the high-end Bakery sort
better of course thank you where you
have to take a chisel to get through to
it wear your bread knife buckles yes and
where you cannot possibly chew
the the contents of that in any fewer
than say 10 solid minutes and two lost
fillings so that I would just say is a
nice loaf of bread why can't they all
make it like yours there we get it maybe
I should eat in a bakery
that I think that they want the
masochistic see that that's why I think
the machismo comes in I think that they
want the massive thick heavy dark
cracked crust I think they want the huge
dents insides because it's you know it's
a bit like the kind of massive rib eye
steaks that some men get really into
yeah you see them in steakhouses where
they order the huge 900 gram piece of
steak with a huge bone going through it
and they're chewing away for hours and
drinking a red wine you could slice in
half I think that's part of that eating
culture it's down a streak of Miss
Andrea here and that it's it's things
that men tend to fixate without question
I mean look yeah like brewing beer for
instance and you're right that men got
obsessed with well a lot of men together
emphasis for making beer and uh there
was this a big fan for hoppy bit you
know lots and hops in a bit and maybe
it's like it's such an extreme yeah uh
that sun beer was just revolting I think
I say in the article that it's a bit
like the do dude Bros you really are not
one of those that's all you're much
nicer you have a much tidier appearance
than these guys they use beard oil and
they have man buns and they look like
18th century Carpenters right these men
and they also like the really extreme
chili infused cocktails they're like
kimchi and fermented stuff like
fermented to next door and back yeah so
they go in for these extremities you're
absolutely right and I think that's how
sourdough has become
parody of itself that to me tastes like
a nice slice of Greek country bread
you know it's it's not
what to be honest it's not sour yeah
well maybe I'm doing but thank you very
much for trying it and to be so polite
you can go and throw up there it's my
pleasure it's a nice tasty piece of
bread uh we shall end it there thank you
very much Beauty and congratulations all
your peace thank you
[Music]
thank you